[Musique]
dans le cadre du plan de relance
économique le département organiser les
rencontres départementales de la
commande publique la collectivité soit
venu accompagner les entreprises pour
répondre aux marchés publics et faire en
sorte qu'ils profitent au plus grand
nombre
nous avons mis en place des ateliers
pour accueillir ces publics
ces ateliers se décline en plusieurs
stands qui nous permettent pour les 1er
2 présenté ce que c'est la commande
publique
comment on y accède donc au travers
notamment de la dématérialisation sur le
patient marchés publics et au travers
également du référencement des
entreprises puisque nous avons mis en
place un système de référencement avec
un fichier qui nous permet de recenser
toutes les entreprises qui sont
intéressés par commande publique de
manière à ce qu'elles puissent
participer à cette commande publique et
qu'elle puisse apprendre à la connaître
un accès simplifié à la commande
publique et a satisfait les
entrepreneurs j'ai voulu participer à
ces ateliers parce que en fait je
réponds à des appels d'offres déjà sur
les collectivités région département et
les berry et il me manquait certains
éléments
par rapport à ça entre autres c'est
d'avoir les alertes sur surtout les les
appels d'offres qui correspondent à ce
que moi je peux proposer
j'ai retrouvé exactement ce que je
venais chercher dans le sens où j'ai
deux ateliers que je viens de faire qui
qui m'ont apporté toutes les réponses à
ce que j'avais besoin
on n'a jamais les faits la commande
publique puisque pour nous c'était
vraiment compliqué de monter le dossier
et aujourd'hui on a eu cette pub là qui
nous disait il ya simplification de la
commande publique et donc on est venu
voir comment ça s'est simplifié vu que
maintenant ça c'est des battes et
réalisé pour sa voix sinon petite
entreprise on pourrait maintenant
facilement répondre à ça j'ai beaucoup
appris aujourd'hui et je trouvais que
c'est quelque chose que on devrait basse
et c'est très bien l'initiative de faire
dans l'est un peu partout et puis c'est
bien organisé il ya beaucoup de gens
notre disposition là et qui nous
expliquent bien même avec des animaux
qui montre le dossier il nous a pas
vraiment inscrit sur le site là et là on
voit bien
toutes les démarches qui en fait la plus
facile ces rencontres départementales de
la commande publique se sont déjà
déroulées dans l'ouest l'est et le sud
la dernière aura lieu le 5 novembre à
l'espace raid l'est à saint-denis
[Musique]